a discovery children's museum in the las  vegas philharmonic have  teamed up this month to teach kids about  music with a safe  hands-on experience for kids in their  after-school study hall program  music van as it's called has helped kids  explore  different kind of musical concepts  including rhythm melody and harmony  the students get a chance to get away  from the screens and away from their  computers  and they get to come in and work with  musicians  and practice using instruments and a  safe distance environment  and it's it's just really uplifting to  see to see them interact  to see this cross-curricular approach to  education  kids need an outlet these days right the  latest program has wrapped up but  the museum is looking to add some more  virtual experiences through the music  van program throughout the winter  and the spring